Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Stabende Arztin auf der Station und würde gerne das Erstgespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, bitte.
Ok, so als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Martin Leber.
Martin Leber. Herr Leber, könntest du Ihren Vornamen bestätigen?
Mein Vornamen ist Martin.
Ok, danke schön. Und wie alt sind Sie, Herr Leber?
Ich bin 62.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
6. Juni 1972.
Ok, wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
1 Meter und 77.
77?
77, ja.
Ok, und wie viel wiegen Sie?
98.
Ok, wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausarztin heißt Yener Kaplan.
Mit S ist Yener.
Ja.
Mit Y.
Ja, erste Bustavie an Y.
Yener.
Ok. Und was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich habe seit zwei Monaten eine juckende und blutende Wunde in meinem Mund.
Mund?
Ja, Mund.
Ok.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ich habe seit zwei Monaten.
Zwei Monate.
Wie genau sind diese Beschwerden?
In der unteren Lippe.
Und keine Schmerzen.
Ok.
Aber Jücken und manchmal Blut.
Haben Sie früher Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, ich habe früher nicht Beschwerden gehabt.
Erstmal?
Ja.
Ok, denken Sie, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser?
Ja, besonders ist es Zitrone.
Zitrone ist unangenehm.
Unangenehm.
Aber keine Schmerzen?
Nein, keine Schmerzen, aber verschiedene Gefühle.
Ok.
Haben Sie eine Schmerzen oder Überwärmung mit der unteren Lippe?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Rottenschwerden oder Überwärmungen?
Ok.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, keine.
Ich habe keine Fieber.
Ok.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß oder Schutterfroß?
Nein, nie.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewöhnlich ab oder zugenommen?
Ja, das ist interessant.
Mein Appetit ist gut.
Aber seit 10 Monaten habe ich ca. 12 Kilo abgenommen.
Entschuldigung.
Zugenommen.
Zugenommen?
Nein, abgenommen.
Ok.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Haben Sie andere Begleitsymptome mit diesen Schmerzen?
Haben Sie nur eine Wunde im Mund oder haben Sie 50 Wunden in anderen Körperteilen aus?
Ich habe seit 10 Monaten Schlafstörungen.
Dagegen nehme ich Pflanzenmedikament ein.
Wissen Sie die Name des Medikaments?
Nein, ich kenne nichts.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Durchschlafen oder Einschlafen?
Ja, ich habe Einschlafen.
Haben Sie Hüsten oder Atemnot?
Ja, ich rauche sehr viel.
Ich habe Hüsten mit schleimigem Sputum.
Seit wann haben Sie Hüsten?
Seit 2 Jahren.
Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie Erbrüche?
Nein, ich habe keine Erbrüche.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich habe viele Erkrankungen.
Ich habe leider eine Zuckerkrankheit.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit 20 Jahren.
Dagegen nehme ich mit Formen 100-1000 mg pro Tag.
Morgens?
Ja, morgens.
Insulin habe ich täglich 6 Einheiten.
Außerdem habe ich Bluthochdruck seit 2 Jahren.
Dagegen nehme ich täglich 5 mg Ramipril.
Morgens oder abends?
Ramipril 2x täglich.
Noch etwas?
Sie haben Blutsuckerkrankheit und Bluthochdruck?
Ja, das ist alles.
Nehmen Sie mit Formen Insulin und Ramipril andere Medikamente ein.
Nein.
Ich habe gesagt, ich nehme flanzliche Medikamente gegen Schlafstörmchen.
Ja, ich habe gemerkt.
Das ist alles.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie raufen. Wie oft raufen Sie? Und seit wann?
Seit 2 Jahren raufe ich.
2 Jahre?
Ja, 10 Jahre.
10 Jahre, okay.
Ich raufe eine Schachtel Zigaretten pro Tag.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke täglich einen kleinen Glas Schnaps.
Okay. Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, keine.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig spazieren.
Wie oft?
Jeden Tag.
Jeden Tag morgens.
Okay, sehr gut. Und sind Sie etwas allergisch?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie.
Sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ja.
Ich habe vorständig geimpft.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Nein, okay. Was waren Sie beruflich?
Früher habe ich als Bürokaufmann gearbeitet.
Bürokaufmann?
Ja.
Sie arbeiten jetzt?
Ja, weiter.
Sie sind verheiratet? Wie ist Ihr Familienstatus?
Ich bin ledig.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder. Ich wohne allein.
Okay. Herr Leber, haben Sie einen Ausfluss bei Ihren Liebungen?
Ich habe einen Ausfluss.
Ist Ihnen ein Ausfluss auf der Wunde?
Ausfluss?
Nasse. Oder eine geäbliche Flüssigkeit?
Nein, keine.
Okay.
Die Bechwerden sind langsam aufgetreten?
Ich habe diese Wunde seit zwei Monaten bemerkt.
Waren Sie für diese Beschwerden bei einem anderen Hausarzt?
Ja. Ich habe meinen Hausarzt besucht.
Er hat mir eine Kortison-Kreme für meine Beschwerden gegeben.
Okay. Hat diese Medikamente oder Kreme geholfen?
Nein, sie haben mir nicht geholfen.
Haben Sie andere Medikamente oder andere Dinge benutzt?
Nein.
Nur Kortison-Kreme?
Ja.
Aber in den letzten Tagen habe ich ein bisschen Fieber.
Sie haben ein bisschen Fieber? Okay. Sie haben ein Fiebergefühl?
Ja. Aber ich habe nicht geholfen.
Haben Sie Nachschweiz oder Schweiß?
Ja. Ich habe besonders Nachschweiß.
Okay.
Herr Leber, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, was ich wissen sollte?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Frau Doktor, ich habe Angst.
Meine Bruder ist vor zwei Jahren an einem Grundschmerzkarzinom gestorben.
Ist das Krebs?
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Angst.
Aber es ist noch zu früh, um etwas Geniales zu sagen.
Um eine deutliche Diagnose zu stellen, müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich möchte fragen, ob es in Ihrer Familie andere chronische Erkrankungen gibt?
Zum Beispiel bei dem Vater oder bei der Mutter.
Haben diese Eltern auch chronische Erkrankungen?
Meine Mutter ist gesund. Sie lebt im Krankenpflege.
Aber mein Vater ist vor zwei Jahren an einem Grundschmerzkarzinfarkt gestorben.
Das tut mir leid.
Aber meine Bruder ist vor zwei Jahren an einem Grundschmerzkarzinfarkt gestorben.
Herr Leber, ich werde zuerst die Körperleute untersuchen, dann Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde einige weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann werden wir Ihre Probleme mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen Geniales sagen.
Ich möchte Sie bitten, noch ein wenig Geduld zu haben.
Okay?
Ich warte Sie.
Okay.
Danke.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Kursat für mich?
Der Patient heißt Martin Leber.
Der Leber ist 62 Jahre alt, 1,67 Meter groß und wiegt 98 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Leber steht heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Monaten.
Er hat eine Wunde im Mund und im unteren Lippen.
Wie groß ist die Wunde?
Ich habe diese Frage nicht gesagt.
Aber bei den Untersuchungen kann ich diese Frage stellen.
Ich habe die Wunde gesehen und ich war ca. 3 cm groß.
Wie tief?
Wie tief? Ich werde bei den Untersuchungen beobachten.
Hat die Wunde eine Ablehnung oder ein Blut?
Die Wunde ist ein bisschen trocken.
Der Patient hat früher keine Beschwerden.
Bei diesen Beschwerden hat der Patient ihren Hausarzt besucht.
Er hat eine Kortisonen-Kreme bei ihm verschieben.
Aber diese Kortisonen-Kreme hat keine Heilung.
Der Wichtstoff sollte geklärt werden.
Die Kreme hilft nicht und hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Diese Mundgeschwühe ist schmerzlos.
Aber er hat eine unangenehme Gefühle nach Zitrone zu essen.
Er hat eine unangenehme Gefühle nach Zitrone zu essen.
Welche Farbe hat die Wunde? Schwarz oder weiß?
Der Patient berichtet, dass diese Wunde keine Rotung, Bewarmung oder Schwierigkeit hatte.
Aber ich sehe, dass es eine Blessewunde ist.
Der Patient klagt seit zwei Jahren.
Der Patient hat einen Gewichtverlust von 12 kg in den letzten sechs Monaten.
Der Patient hat eine Unbefugung.
Aber er hat seine Körpertemperatur nicht gemessen.
Er hat eine Unbefugung.
In der Familienanamnese wurde angegeben, dass sein Vater vor zwei Jahren einen Myokartinfarkt verstorben hat.
Seine Mutter ist gesund, aber sie lebt in Altenpflege.
Seine Mutter leidet in Altenpflege.
Sein Bruder ist vor zwei Jahren an Bronscher Karschnoem verstorben.
Er raucht seit zehn Jahren 20 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Wie viele Packages haben Sie?
Zehn Packages.
Er trinkt täglich kleine Glas Schnaps, drückt Konsum und spaziert jeden Tag.
Er hat keine bekannte Allergie und ist vollständig geif.
Die Reise an Amnese ist unauffällig.
Er arbeitet als Brokaufmann.
Er ist leidig und lebt alleine.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Lippen Karschnoem hin.
Ist es möglich, Diabetes zu haben?
Es ist möglich, Diabetes zu haben.
Der Patient hat zwei Zwangsjagd-Diabetes-Malutus.
Es ist möglich, das zu machen.
Die Beschwerden sollen die folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
Zuerst werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf,
dass der Patient die Farbung des Mundes und die Schwellung und Warmung hat.
dass die Farbung des Mundes und die Schwellung und die Schwellung hat.
Bei der Laboruntersuchung würde ich ein großes Blutbild,
Entzündungsparameter, Nieren- und Lebewerte, Elektrolyte und Vitamin B12 und Vitamin D bestimmen lassen.
Was ist in diesem Fall die C-Markers?
C-Markers? Ich weiss nicht.
Und B-Segue?
Entzündungsparameter.
Natürlich würde ich Entzündungsparameter und Nieren- und Lebewerte und HbA1C bestimmen lassen.
Das ist die Tumormarker, aber ich möchte in diesem Fall eine Tumormarker bestimmen lassen.
Blut senkung, Geschwindigkeit. Kennen Sie?
Blut senkung, Geschwindigkeit. B-Segue.
Das ist eine Tumormarker für diesen Fall?
Nein. Aber seit uns eine unnormalisierte Station ist.
Okay. Und weitere Untersuchungen möchte ich... können Sie schreiben?
Und weitere Untersuchungen möchte ich eine Gewebeprobe auf der Wunde entnehmen
und eine histologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Sollte sich die Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen, schlage ich die folgende Therapie vor.
Bei kleineren oder wenn die Tumor keine Methasthen hat, würde ich eine exkiseionale Biopsie durchführen.
Aber wenn der Patient Methasthen hat, würde ich eine Chemotherapie beginnen.
So erst werde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und würde ich einen Zugang legen und eine ausreichende Flüssigkeit verabreichen.
Dann eine onkologische Konzentration.
Und in einer Wunde ohne Methasthen würde ich eine exkiseionale Biopsie durchführen.
Aber wenn der Patient Methasthen hat, würde ich eine exkiseionale Biopsie durchführen.
Aber wenn der Patient Methasthen hat, würde ich eine Chemotherapie beginnen.
Welche Typen denken Sie in diesem Karzino?
Welche Typen Karzino?
Ja, Basalselz Karzino.
Ich weiße Histologie.
Schwarze Karzino, weiße Karzino.
Ich habe keine Vermutung.
Haben Sie Vermutung?
Nein, ich habe keine Vermutung.
Ich vermute in diesem Fall Basalselz Karzino.
Weiß Karzino, weiße Krebs.
Kennen Sie Schwarzkrebs?
Nein.
Malin Melanum, Schwarzkrebs?
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Arthritisierungen herpesoster sind.
Wie können sie herpesoster auslösen?
Die Herpesinfektionen können in der Herpeswahl sein.
Sie haben eine immunologische Befunde.
Anti-IgM, Anti-IgG.
Für Herpes?
Ja.
Ja, wir können beurteilen.
Wie können Sie Pilzeinfektionen im Mund auslösen?
In der histologischen Untersuchung kann diese Verdachtstheatome ausgeschlossen werden.
Können Sie uns Petsiti aufklären?
Petsiti ist ein Bildgebungsverfahren, um die Metastasen zu bestätigen.
Nur Metastasen oder alle kalten Stoffwechselkrankheiten oder Geschwurz.
Gehwurzt.
Ja, Metastasen auch.
Okay.
Der Patient gibt eine spezielle Flüssigkeit.
Flüssigkeit oder intravenös.
Intravenös, ja.
Die radioaktive Marke.
Wir warten auf eine Stunde, um die radioaktive Substanz der Körper des Patienten zu verbreiten.
Okay.
Diese Untersuchung ist schmerzlos.
Der Patient hat keine Vorbereitung.
Okay.
Nach der Untersuchung kann der Patient seine Atak weitergehen.
Aber wir gehen nicht auf die radioaktive Substanz.
Der Patient sollte allein in einem Zimmer bleiben.
Ca. drei Tage.
Welche Personen wird der Patient kontaktiert?
Kinder oder Schwangerschaft.
Schwangerschaft, ja.
Muss keinen Kontakt haben.
Muss der Patient viele Wasser trinken, um die radioaktive Substanz auszuscheiden?
Nach der Untersuchung?
Ja, viele trinken.
Der Patient muss ca. drei Liter täglich trinken.
Hat diese Untersuchung alternative Methoden?
Für PET.
CT?
Ja, wir können auch eine CT-Grafik, aber nein.
Die Chemikerin hat etwas gemacht, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Densitometer.
Es gibt keine alternative Methoden, aber wir können die CT-Grafik ausführen.
Aber es ist sehr teuer.
Ja, sehr teuer. Und der Patient mit CT hat viele Strahlung.
Das ist nicht eine gute Wahl.
PET-CT?
Nein, CT.
Okay, vielen Dank für die Kollegen.
Vielen Dank.